my
hello everyone
welcome to this full course video on
machine learning algorithms machine
learning algorithms have been commonly
used in industries such as e-commerce
manufacturing and healthcare to build
complex machine learning models our
experienced instructors will help you
understand the intuition behind these
algorithms
you will start by understanding the
basics of machine learning from a short
animated video then you will learn some
of the top supervised learning
algorithms such as linear regression
logistic regression decision trees
support vector machines and k-nearest
neighbors
moving further we will shift our focus
on unsupervised learning algorithms such
as k-means clustering and principal
component analysis
finally we look at reinforcement
learning and q learning algorithm now
all these algorithms will be covered
with extensive hands-on demonstrations
in python so let's begin
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do and much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x-axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if you draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas one word for dislike if we
go for the majority votes we can say
that paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called
k-nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
their label when you feed this data to
the machine learning model it learns
which feature is associated with which
slip for example it will learn that if a
coin is of 3 grams it will be a 1 rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario 1 facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fare of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the search pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 00 pm today okay
i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you where machines are
learning and doing amazing jobs so
that's all for machine learning basics
today from my site keep watching this
space for more interesting videos until
then happy learning
welcome to linear regression my name is
richard kirchner i'm with simply learn
let's look at an example of a common use
for linear regression profit estimation
of a company if i was going to invest in
a company i would like to know how much
money i could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our rnd which is
your research and development we have
our marketing
we might have the location we might have
what kind of administration is going
through based on all this different
information we would like to calculate
the profit now in actuality there's
usually about 23 to 27 different markers
that they look at if they're a heavy
duty investor we're only going to take a
look at one basic one we're going to
come in and for simplicity let's
consider a single variable r and d and
find out which companies to invest in
based on that so we take r and d we're
plotting the profit based on the r and d
expenditure how much money they put into
the research and development and then we
look at the profit that goes with that
we can predict a line to estimate the
profit so we draw a line right through
the data when you look at that you can
see how much they invest in the r d is a
good marker as to how much profit
they're going to have we can also note
that companies spending more on r d make
good profit so let's invest in the ones
that spend a higher rate in their r d
what's in it for you first we'll have an
introduction to machine learning
followed by machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in let's start with our
introduction to machine learning along
with some machine learning algorithms
and where that fits in with linear
regression let's look at another example
machine learning based on the amount of
rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so we here we have our crops we
have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary
height where categorical would be a
description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions qriket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is
m in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y2
minus y1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we
have c which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum of x times
y which we computed one line at a time
there and that's just the 66 and take
all that and you subtract it from the
sum of x times the sum of y and those
have both been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines times the sum of x
squared easily computed as 86 for the
sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have uh well we'll start with the
simple linear regression where we had y
equals m plus x plus c and we're trying
to find the value of y now with multiple
linear regression we have multiple
variables coming in so instead of having
just x we have x1 x2 x3 and instead of
having just one slope each variable has
its own slope attached to it as you can
see here we have m1 m2 m3 and we still
just have the single coefficient so when
you're dealing with multiple linear
regression you basically take your
single linear regression and you spread
it out so you have y equals m1 times x1
plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
um just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed matte plot
library inline that is only because i'm
doing an inline ide my interface in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables in fact it's
not going to do anything that we can see
but it is importing these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies dot csv you're going to have
to change this to fit whatever setup you
have and the file itself you can request
just go down to the commentary below
this video and put a note in there and
simply learn we'll try to get in contact
with you and supply you with that file
so you can try this coding yourself so
we're going to add this code in here and
we're going to see that i have companies
equals pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of 136 897
dollars and 80 cents so on so on helps
to create the profit of 192 261 and 83
cents that makes no sense to me
whatsoever no pun intended so let's flip
back here and take a look at our next
set of code where we're going to graph
it so we can get a better understanding
of our data and what it means so at this
point we're going to use a single line
of code to get a lot of information so
we can see where we're going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the
matplot library in line with the amber
sign at the beginning so here we come
down to the single line of code seaborne
is great because it actually recognizes
the panda data frame so i can just take
the companies dot core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot and let's just take a
look at what this plot means if you look
at this plot on mine the colors are
probably a little bit more purplish and
blue than the original one uh we have
the columns and the rows we have r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r d spending and
the same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital l label capital e encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why
because the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferred all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon all this
is doing is removing that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
y what this is is x is our data going in
that's our rnd spin our administration
our marketing and then y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this tutorial the next
part train test split we take x and we
take y we've already created those x has
the columns with the data in it and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size equals
0.2 that basically means 20 percent
so 20 of the rows are going to be tested
we're going to put them off to the side
so since we're using a thousand lines of
data that means that 200 of those lines
we're going to hold off to the side to
test for later and then the random state
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting because it's setting
up our variables but the next step is
the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model we get
that next piece of the puzzle let's go
ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn
linear underscore model we're going to
import linear regression now i don't
know if you recall from earlier when we
were doing all the math let's go ahead
and flip back there and take a look at
that do you remember this where we had
this long formula on the bottom and we
were doing all this summarization and
then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print y predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope 1 times
column 1 variable plus slope two times
column two variable all the way to the m
into the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus eight point eight nine to the
power of two et cetera et cetera times
the first column and the second column
and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the why
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression as i mentioned earlier
positive regression is an algorithm for
performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the near future so this is
like a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the x and
y axis x is the number of years since
the last service was performed and why
is the probability of your car breaking
down and let's say this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car users it's not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this graph we can find out
whether your car will break down or not
we'll see how so first of all the
probability can go from zero to one as
you're aware probability can be between
zero and one and as we can imagine it is
intuitive as well as the number of years
are on the lower side maybe one year two
years or three years till after the
service the chances of your car breaking
down are very limited right so for
example chances of your car breaking
down the probability of your car
breaking down within two years of your
last service are 0.1 probability
similarly three years is maybe 0.3 and
so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the
why that we are talking about the
dependent variable that we are talking
about what we are looking at is whether
the car is going to break down or not
yes or no that is what we are talking
about so here the outcome is discrete
and not a continuous value so this is
how the logistic regression curve looks
let me explain a little bit what exactly
how exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
us it is trained and it learns from this
labeled information so that when a new
employees information is fed based on
the rating it will determine what should
be the height so this is a linear
regression problem
linear regression example now salary is
a continuous value you can get 5
5600 it is not discreet like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you
are trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out if that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is a
rating for which people got promotion we
just plotted the data about whether a
person has got an employer's got
promotion or not yes no right so there
is nothing in between and what is the
employees rating okay and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clipped
at 0 and 1. but still the straight line
doesn't look right therefore instead of
using a linear equation we need to come
up with something different and
therefore the logistic regression
model looks somewhat like this so we
calculate the probability and if we plot
that probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and this is
how the math behind logistic regression
looks so we are trying to find the odds
for a particular event happening and
this is the formula for finding the odds
so the probability of an event happening
divided by the probability of the event
not happening so p if it is the
probability of the event happening
probability of the person getting a
promotion and divided by the probability
of the person not getting a promotion
that is 1 minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes one then the value
of the odds is one by zero that will be
infinity but the probability itself
remains between zero and one now this is
how an equation of a straight line looks
so y is equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 x
where beta0 is the y intercept and beta
1 is the slope of the line if we take
the odds equation and take a log of both
sides then this would look somewhat like
this and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of px by 1 minus px
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of px you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if you want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is a
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a 2 here there are there's a
1 here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed or rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum member should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
hundred percent accuracy everything will
be only in the diagonal there will be no
numbers other than zero in all other
cells so that is like a hundred percent
accurate model okay so that's uh just of
how to use this matrix uh how to use
this uh confusion matrix i know the name
uh is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and
the predicted value and the actual value
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and the accuracy
is only 37 of them have been accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven and two of
them have been predicted as number eight
and so on and so forth okay all right so
with that let's go into jupiter notebook
and see how the code looks so this is
the code in
in jupyter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code
then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like 8x8 images so
that's that's what is reflected in this
shape now from here onwards we are
basically once again importing some of
the libraries that are required like
numpy and matplot and we will take a
look at
some of the sample images that we have
uh loaded so this one for example
creates a figure and then we go ahead
and take a few sample images to see how
they look so let me run this code and so
that it becomes easy to understand so
these are about five images sample
images that we are looking at zero one
two three four so this is how the image
is this is how the data is okay and
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and
each pixel whether it is activated or
not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training
we split the data into training and test
so that the training data set is used to
train the system so we pass this
probably multiple times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the labor so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is 4 1 4 so actually there are
414 observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit-learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call this the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set right this is our the
predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 to accurate okay so that's on this
part now what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix
is equal to the number of observations
in the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predicted value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's uh it's like more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course 0
then this is the image of 9
so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is the image of 1
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify
images what is a decision tree let's go
through a very simple example before we
dig in deep decision tree is a tree
shape diagram used to determine a course
of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root note the topmost decision note is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get the jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with the
gun or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals and
let's try to classify different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree so the problem statement
is to classify the different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree the data set is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so let's look at a training
set or a training data set and we're
looking at color we're looking at height
and then we have our different animals
we have our elephants our giraffes our
monkeys and our tigers and they're of
different colors and shapes let's see
what that looks like and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
that split the data in such a way that
the information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base 2 of the
same the percentage of that animal let's
try to calculate the entropy for the
current data set and take a look at what
that looks like and don't be afraid of
the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case let's say it's yellow fence
two over eight two elephants over total
of eight times log base two two over
eight plus one monkey over total of
eight log base two one over eight and
plus two over eight of the tigers log
base two over eight and if we plug that
into our computer our calculator i
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to point five 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we will
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has decreased considerably
however we still need some splitting of
both the branches to attain an entropy
value equal to zero so we decide to
split both the nodes using height as a
condition since every branch now
contains single label type we can say
that entropy in this case has reached
the least value and here you see we have
the giraffes the tigers the monkey and
the elephants all separated into their
own groups this tree can now predict all
the classes of animals present in the
data set with 100 percent accuracy that
was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so i'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our our setup that's the
whole reason we're splitting it between
the training and testing data and
finally we still need the sklearn import
tree and that's just the basic tree
function is needed for the decision tree
classifier and finally we're going to
load our data down here and i'm going to
run this and we're going to get two
things on here one we're going to get an
error and two we're going to get a
warning let's see what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says i need to read a
file and when this was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and they decided to keep one of those
and eventually get rid of the other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with uh the first one being a column and
then one 000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a word doc where it's all
scrunched together and hard to read you
can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns 1 through 5. remember
we always start with zero zero is a yes
or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one if
we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x trade or the y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of 3.
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals means it's only going to go
down three layers before it stops and
then we have minimal samples of leafs is
five so it's going to have at least five
leafs at the end so i'll have at least
three splits or have no more than three
layers and at least five end leaves with
the final result at the bottom now that
we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules that
their different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y predict e n to
print it i could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here and this tells you which each one
of those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal and we
want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as the final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training
we can look at that we know that that's
what's going to come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true then it comes
out as the orange and if it's false that
leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes those decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here
a high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it into and if you look at these
new data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals uh decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
uh definitions we'll look at the leaf
node and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
uh that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with a dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
and we have a label apple lemon grapes
apple lemon grapes and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
to split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest and it's
very key to note that we're looking for
the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right it still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is how does a random forest
work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false or true and so on and
so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees you can see them
all in one image so this would be three
completely different trees categorizing
a fruit and let's take a fruit now let's
try this and this fruit if you look at
it we've blackened it out you can't see
the color on it so it's missing data
remember one of the things we talked
about earlier is that a random forest
works really good if you're missing data
if you're missing pieces so this fruit
has an image but maybe the person had a
black and white camera when they took
the picture and we're going to take a
look at this and it's going to have they
put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one is the diameter greater
than equal to three is the color orange
well it doesn't really know on this one
but if you look at the value and say
true and go to the right tree two
classifies it as cherries is the color
equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the sklearn
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sk learn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in and one is going to be pandas
we're going to import pandas as pd pd is
a common term used for pandas and pandas
is basically creates a data format for
us where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports and i'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and
data is equal to the different data
we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head will print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in python most
arrays always start at zero so when you
look at the first five it's going to be
zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our
iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're going to take a look
at the target and let's go ahead and get
this into our notebook this piece of
code so we can discuss it a little bit
more in detail so here we are in our
jupyter notebook i'm going to put the
code in here and before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target
now these are both in the pandas setup
on here so in pandas we can do either
one i could have just as easily done
iris and then in brackets target
depending on what i'm working on both
are
acceptable let's go ahead and run this
code and see how this changes and what
we've done is we've added the target
from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're gonna add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you where you where
that's different where you can alter
that and do it slightly differently but
let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to that now and here we go
we're going to put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test seventy-five percent
in train twenty-five percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
original data frame with the iris data
in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in
and you'll see here we've done a couple
very basic things we know that the
columns in our data frame again this is
a panda thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features and the shorthand is you just
put features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd.factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what is factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there and looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and i printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the endnotes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn
and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here for
today though all we need to do is fit or
train our features and our target y so
now we have our training model what's
next if we're going to create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length sepal width pedal length
pedal width so when we put it in this
way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts zero zero zero one two one one
two two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one
for setosa it predicts a 0 for virginica
and it predicts a 0 for versa color and
so on and so on and so on and let's um
you know what i'm going to change this
just a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets .5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the virginica since these two
are equal and so on and so on down the
list you can see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features and we've
looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run that we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable
and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts uh mapping it to all
the different flower types the versa
color and the virginica in there and
let's see how this goes with the next
one so let's take a look at the top part
of our species in here and we'll take
this code and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test
model and then we come down here we look
at test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satoshi satosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what are
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're gonna create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data and creates a
chart out of them so when i run it
you'll get a nice chart down here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale-up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more last week my
son and i visited a fruit shop dad is
that an apple or a strawberry so the
question comes up what fruit do they
just pick up from the fruit stand after
a couple of seconds you could figure out
that it was a strawberry so let's take
this model a step further and let's uh
why not build a model which can predict
an unknown data and in this we're going
to be looking at some sweet strawberries
or crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories
and in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on the graph so we
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a 2-dimensional output as
you can see in this picture here the 1d
when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine
we'll start with high dimensional input
space or sometimes referred to as the
curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension two dimension
three dimension when you get to a
thousand dimensions a lot of problems
start occurring with most algorithms
that have to be adjusted for the svm
automatically does that in high
dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words in documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or it's going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive in to
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo when we have the young child
going dead is that a group of crocodiles
or alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go ahead and
put our code in there and one of the
things i like about the jupiter notebook
is i go up to view and i'm going to go
ahead and toggle the line numbers on to
make it a little bit easier to talk
about and we can even increase the size
because this is edited in this case i'm
using google chrome explorer and that's
how it opens up for the editor although
anyone any like i said any editor will
work now the first step is going to be
our imports and we're going to import
four different parts the first two i
want you to look at are line one and
line two are numpy as np and matplot
library dot pi plot as plt now these are
very standardized imports when you're
doing work the first one is the numbers
python we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses that for the
numpy array and i'll talk about that in
a minute so you can understand why we
want to use a numpy array versus the
standard python array and normally it's
pretty standard setup to use np for
numpy the map plot library is how we're
going to view our data so this has you
do need the np for the sklearn module
but the map plot library is purely for
our use for visualization and so you
really don't need that for the svm but
we're going to put it there so you have
a nice visual aid and we can show you
what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're going to i'm going to jump
one ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your
setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use and finally we have our
actual svm the sklearn import svm on
line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20 so
which each each group is going to have
20 different pieces of data in it and
the way that it looks is that we'll have
under x um an x y plane so i have two
numbers under x and y will be 0 1 that's
the two different centers so we have yes
or no in this case alligator or
crocodile that's what that represents
and then i told you that the actual sk
learner the svm is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with clf equals
dot svc kernel equals linear and i set
sql to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma 0. we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one so we have column zero and
column one and you can look at this as
our x y plots the first one is the x
plot and the second one is the y plot so
the first one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8
and 10 and then the second one x of the
one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the
left hand side s equals 30 is just the
size of the dots we can see them and
said little tiny dots
and then the c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
uh fit was done in two lines of code a
lot of times will be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1 so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph we're going to spend more
work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and i'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and i'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three
and four is the same code we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're gonna fit the values
on our svm and then we're gonna plot
scatter it and then we're gonna do a
plot show so you should be asking why
are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is a very standard note used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small x x equals np line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the xx
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital xx with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array xy array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function and we're going to put
the x y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have uh three levels of
data the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column zero and column one
and then again we have the s equals one
hundred so we're gonna make them larger
and the line width equals one face
colors equals none let's take a look and
see what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph we
have our two support vectors and dashed
lines and they have the near data so you
can see those two points or in this case
the four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth today we're
going to cover the k nearest neighbors
let's refer to as k n n and k n is
really a fundamental place to start in
the machine learning it's the basis of a
lot of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is knn
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use knn
how does knn algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has a smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and goes in
the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for it's one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or it's not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals 5 i mean that's
what's the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose a factor k k n algorithm is based
on feature similarity choosing the right
value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values and whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your k value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use k n when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13 and distance 3 is
about 13.4 similarly we will calculate
the euclidean distance of unknown data
point from all the points in the data
set and because we're dealing with small
amount of data that's not that hard to
do it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the euclidean
distance hence we have calculated the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where x1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance who's going to be
their closest neighbors now let's
calculate the nearest neighbor at k
equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hints as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so recap of k n n positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight um eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
uh very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see i have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so that they're
all uniform between -1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three
are three tools to test all about
testing our model how good is it we just
put down test on there and we have our
confusion matrix our f1 score and our
accuracy so we have our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six modules specific from
the sk learn setup and then we do need
to go ahead and run this so these are
actually imported there we go and then
move on to the next step and so in this
set we're going to go ahead and load the
database we're going to use pandas
remember pandas is pd and we'll take a
look at the data in python we looked at
it in a simple spreadsheet but usually i
like to also pull it up so that we can
see what we're doing so here's our data
set equals pd.read csv that's a pandas
command and the diabetes folder i just
put in the same folder where my ipython
script is if you put in a different
folder you need the full length on there
we can also do a quick links of the data
set that is a simple python command
l-e-n for length we might even let's go
ahead and print that we'll go print and
if you do it on its own line link that
data set the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i use i always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan in numpy nan
is what that stands for is none doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the zero in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead hope
they just didn't get the data the next
thing we want to do is we're going to
create the mean which is the integer
from the data set from the column dot
mean where we skip n a's we can do that
that is a pandas command there the skip
n a so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data set and then we're
going to take that data set column and
we're going to replace all the npn with
the means why did we do that we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replaced
zero and skip anything where except you
could actually there's a way to skip
zeros and then just replace all the
zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value and we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sk learn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 percent of the data and
put it aside so that we can test it
later that's all that is and again we're
going to run it not very exciting so far
we haven't had any printout other than
to look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scal the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to 6 we're going to set that
all so that all the data is between -1
and 1. that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized and we only
want to fit the scalar with the training
set but we want to make sure the testing
set is the x test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it sc
underscore x for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our x train
equals sc underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
and if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in no no
we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are the diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do let's just do
p-r-e-d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94
and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here and that column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is at 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix
then we're going to go ahead and print
the f1 score let me just run that and
you see we get a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account and that's what most
people think of is it looks at just how
many we got right out of how many we got
wrong so a lot of people when you're a
data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
it tells us it is a pretty fair fit in
the model what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is
an unsupervised learning algorithm in
this case you don't have labeled data
unlike in supervised learning so you
have a set of data and you want to group
them and as the name suggests you want
to put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together so that's what k means
clustering is all about the term k is
basically is a number so we need to tell
the system how many clusters we need to
perform so if k is equal to two there
will be two clusters if k is equal to
three three clusters and so on and so
forth that's what the k stands for and
of course there is a way of finding out
what is the best or optimum value of k
for a given data we will look at that so
that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and boilers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is
so there are information there is
information on the y-axis about the
runts code and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and
the distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-main's clustering algorithm and
then we will end with a demo and a use
case for k-means clustering so let's
begin first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
the glomerulative clustering is a
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have abcdef
we start by combining bmc form one
cluster d e and e form one more then we
combine d e and f one more bigger
cluster and then add bc to that and then
finally a to it compared to that
divisive clustering or divisive
clustering is a top down approach we
begin with the whole set and proceed to
divide it into successively smaller
clusters so we have abcdef we first take
that as a single cluster and then break
it down
into a b c d
e and f then we have partitional
clustering split into two subtypes k
means clustering and fuzzy c means in
k-means clustering the objects are
divided into the number of clusters
mentioned by the number k that's where
the k comes from so if we say k is equal
to 2 the objects are divided into two
clusters c1 and c2 and the way it is
done is the features or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how k means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of
wireless sensor networks the clustering
algorithm plays the role of finding the
cluster heads which collects all the
data in its respective cluster so
clustering especially k means clustering
uses distance measure so let's take a
look at what is distance measure so
while these are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on k-means clustering so distance
measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root we leave the square as it is
and then we have manhattan distance
measure in case of manhattan distance it
is the sum of the distances across the
x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k
now let's go and check how exactly
k-means clustering works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares
and the lower this value is the better
the cluster is that means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that is taken as the optimum
value of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y-axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
witnesses value will be very high
because they are probably scattered all
over the moment you split it into two
there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases the decrease the rate of
decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either 2 or 3 or at the most 4
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been randomly assigned points and
only thing that has been done was the
data points which are closest to them
have been assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is a
repetitive process iterative process and
if the centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster so i
hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of
k-means clustering so let's take a look
at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
central point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the mean positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of x one
from the centroid c one
c two c three and then c which is the
lowest value and assign x one to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 was probably
assigned to cluster c2 and after doing
this calculation maybe now x1 is
assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number 2
we now have all the points all the data
points grouped into k groups because we
we wanted to create k clusters right so
we have k groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales so
how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on and we are loading
the data that is available in the form
of let's say the addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual k-means clustering
process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are the
optimal distance which is the shortest
distance and assign each of the points
data points to the centroids and then go
through this iterative process till the
whole process converges and finally we
get an output like this so we have four
distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for the stores in florida
so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are learning
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupyter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify
how many clusters we want so centers we
are mentioning here so it will go ahead
and so we just mentioned four so it will
go ahead and create some test data for
us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as with any other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function or the method
rather fit is what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values the data
that has been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
why underscore k means solve with the
cluster numbers that have been assigned
for each observation so this is the
cluster number assigned for observation
1 maybe this is for observation 2
observation 3 and so on so we have how
many about i think 300 samples right so
all the 300 samples there are 300 values
here each of them the cluster number is
given and the cluster number goes from 0
to 3. so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from 0 1 2 three so that's
what is seen here okay now so this was a
quick example of generating some dummy
data and then clustering that okay and
this can be applied if you have proper
data you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real life examples
real life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing k means clustering
and there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process still the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001 we can
consider that as convergence otherwise
what will happen is this will either
take forever or it will be never ending
so that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation uh this is like a kind of
a rough implementation of the k-means
clustering okay so if we execute this
code this is what we get as the output
so this is the definition of this
particular function and then we call
that find underscore clusters and we
pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is 4
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k means
clustering and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image
and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
jpg okay so let me load that and this is
how it looks this is the original image
which has i think 16 million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between 0 and 1 and the way to do that
is divide by 255 so we divide china by
255 and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between 0 and one right
so if you earlier noticed in case of
china the values were large numbers now
everything is between zero and one this
is one of the things we need to do all
right so after that the next thing that
we need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this is how
the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is a
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
it pretty much looks like the original
image yes we can see that for example
here there is a little bit it appears a
little dullish compared to this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again uh
we can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will
also bring this as you can see the
numbers are much big so we will much
bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as the next step we
will go ahead and visualize this how it
looks there's the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see
this looks much richer in color but at
the same time and this probably doesn't
have as we can see it doesn't look as
rich as this one but nevertheless the
information is not lost the shape and
all that stuff and this can be also
rendered on a slightly a device which is
probably not that sophisticated okay so
that's pretty much it so we have seen
two examples of how color compression
can be done uh using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering the principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpex isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order id a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the xy
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and
pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc one and not
the pc2 as the data points are more
spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point all those points fall
onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever altering it and the eigenvalue
is the final value that we generate
we talk about standardization the main
aim of this step is to standardize the
range of the attributes so that each one
of them lie within similar boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature or two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
iogene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
igine values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the igene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so we have like multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables
now for this matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents
the maximum variance direction in the
data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python 3.
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
are data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on that plot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
one of the reasons a cancer data set is
is it has like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set as we have
our data we have our target our frame
target names description feature names
and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain
we want to focus on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from you can actually see
the actual different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9 um so in other
words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
then we can go ahead and load our data
and uh you know let me go up a just a
notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data our we're going to use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most the data
that comes in half the time we don't
even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is
from sk learn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
uh and then the pca fit we're going to
is going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
uh which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our minimum
maximum we've already looked at what's
in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of one these are two
different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principle component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it we can look at this and
say hey this one actually did a pretty
good job
of separating the data
and a couple of things when i'm looking
at this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here and that middle
line where the overlap is going to be
huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components
it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the uh
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing
what this means and so let me go ahead
and just put this down i've already got
it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us when we want and so
we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example but we'll
teach a tic tac toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50 pound
object how does that change how a robot
would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth that
technology is capable of machines need
to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions
we want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it so we're
looking at
our different systems are different
model we have supervised versus
unsupervised versus reinforcement
learning and with the supervised
learning that is probably the most
controlled environment we have a lot of
different supervised learning models
whether it's linear regression neural
networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock you can already have like the
graph of what the next day looks like so
you have an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning is part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used
no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model i'll see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market uh in machine learning
or growing market it's very it's very
infant stage
as far as how it works and what it's
going to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this
it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know we have
the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
whether using a neural network or a
q table or whatever combination thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get chest full of
gyms or whatever and that's the output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here the environment is
a whole game board so if you're playing
one of those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what is your
action that you're you're going to take
what's the policy you're using to have
an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate uh
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work so it's a little tricky but
the policy thing is actually pretty cool
how it works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
uh so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them
and then you have an action we want to
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence we'll follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
uh so you have you know so we start off
with fetching it goes oh i get a biscuit
for that it tries something else you get
a handshake or begging or something like
that and goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring his biscuit
and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration
so there's a little randomness going on
in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything um
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent
uh the agent then looks at this uh state
or it looks at the reward usually um
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and then looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
um and then we have a reward the policy
is that part that's connected at the
bottom
and so it looks at that policy and says
hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
um
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment
sends it says hey this is the agent did
this if you're a character in a game
this happened
and it shoots out a reward in a state
the agent looks at the reward looks at
the new state and then takes a little
guess and says i'm going to try this
action and then that action goes back
into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b
is an action reward is a cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or it
can go right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
um a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here um and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work uh or
a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems
and we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic tac toe game
but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's gonna find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new
python folder in this case i've already
done it and enabled it to change the
name to tic-tac-toe and then for this
example uh we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for storing different
information different states that we're
going to go through on here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
we have player one player two
uh is end we're gonna create a board
hash
uh we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just gonna store some information
in there symbol player equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization
then something simple we're just going
to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for
let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simply learn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
diagonals so you gotta check the
diagonal that's what all this stuff does
here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and put
there we go
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
uh minus three just says did somebody
win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before
this way when you try something or the
computer tries something
it's not going to give it an illegal
move that's what the available positions
is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code uh so
really it's kind of a thing you'd want
to go through and play with a little bit
and just read through it get a copy of
it a great way to understand how this
works
and here is a given reward um so we're
going to give a reward result equal self
winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result itself.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
if it doesn't equal one then it gets a
zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a three by
three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
uh certainly you only have so many
actions but your environment is huge you
have a lot going on in the environment
and suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you can actually get a reward in
this case you get the reward at the end
of the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it and
then of course there's the play we want
to go ahead and play rounds equals 100
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you can obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things it beats this we've seen this in
chess i think was a big one where they
had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning
was one of the ways they trained one of
the top
computer chess playing algorithms
so this is just what this is it's going
to choose an action it's going to try
something and the more i try stuff
the more we're going to record the the
hash we actually have a board hash where
they self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
then we go back and reset and try again
and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play with a human so we'll get a chance
to come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things um or sees if it
wins or ties
um
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out how do we reward it
and how do we guess the next best action
so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
we want to go ahead and create our agent
in this case our player so each one is
going to grab that
until we look at a class player
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
uh that it can look at and reward uh so
we want to take a look at this we have
uh name
self-state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma
explorate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one to see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it
the 10 is going to count more than the
first step
uh and here's our we're going to
get the board information coming in and
then choose an action this was the
second part that i was talking about
that was so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
um and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states
choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board
for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash date
what's the last date append it to the uh
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
uh what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
this and this is really important this
is this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
uh step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of ten
uh so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here right before
10 was
let's say it's also 10 it just makes the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 in whatever
it is but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9. that's a 0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
uh it basically adds in it says here's
one or here's two i'm sorry i should
have done this abc would have been
easier
so the first move goes in here and puts
two in here
uh then we have our self
set up on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the when to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards and i want to sum
them up going in reverse and i want to
find the answer in reverse kind of an
interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on let's go
ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what uh let's
go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must have forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there's actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
uh so now i've only set this up
with
see where we go in here i've only set
this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player 1 is going to
be the computer experience rate 0 load
policy 1
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1. you can see this is very uh
basic on here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm gonna
go zero block it zero zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and
human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five
let's do five thousand or fifty thousand
i think that's what the guys in the back
had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it
on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a few
minutes or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this this took
i got a pretty powerful processor and it
took
about five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player set up on here oops
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go one one which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom uh so you can see here
we've got a didn't catch the win on this
it said tie
kind of funny that didn't catch the win
on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important uh machine
learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what's the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different
values you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit skillup by simplylearn click on
the link in the description to know more
a quick uh recap so we're going to go
back and do a reinforcement learning
recap and you'll remember we have our
agent our action our environment and our
reward
and the state
and so reinforcement learning is a
branch of machine learning that trains a
model to come to an optimum solution for
a problem
by taking decisions by itself
so we look at it we analyze the data
make decisions solve problems
it consists of an environment which an
agent will interact with to learn to
reach a goal or perform an action and
you see here we have the dog
and the action equals fetching
and the first thing
you're going to notice here and i'll
talk a little bit more about this
is that our action is kind of a
singularity the action isn't a
regression type model where we're
looking at float numbers
or we're trying to predict something
or doing a reinforcement learning where
we're trying to guess the value of the
stock market where you have
three five 5.33
and thirty three cents this is very a
little bit different and uh you'll see
why q learning is so powerful but also
where it falls short
uh the agent is also given reward if the
action performed by it is bringing is
closer to the goal is leading to the
goal this is done to train the model in
the right direction we have a reward of
a hopefully a doggy cookie and action
equals fetching so gets a reward it gets
to go fetch the ball
reinforcement learning can be divided
based on whether the machine uses a
model to learn or learns by itself
so reinforcement learning it's model
based learn the model given model
and you can think of neural networks i
think are the most common right now used
for reinforcement learning there
certainly are a lot of other options out
there
but you have
this black box and you go back and you
send the error back up and it trains it
based on how much of an error the error
could be computed based on maybe a
maximum reward
subtraction or something like that so
the closer you get to
the maximum reward the better
and so we talk about a model free
you have your policy optimization and
your q learning
and
this is kind of the cool thing about q
learning is it can do it's very powerful
on certain things making it very quick
and easy to do a reinforcement learning
so what is q learning q learning is
reinforcement learning policy which will
fill the next best action given a
current state it chooses this action at
random and aims to maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chessboard where is it
at in the video game
if your robots out there picking trash
up off the side of the road where is it
at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning we can make an ad
recommendation system which will suggest
related products to our previous
purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms we talk about q learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again uh when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action this might be if you're playing a
video game your character stepped in and
is now dead or whatever
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state
and action and previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be
and take that state the optimist the
optimal state will give us the highest
optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your essay so
your current state and your action
then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
uh so we're looking at these just like
any other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps you don't really
have that approach to
the solution you just have a jump and
then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection
i'll go into the random selection in
just a second steps in q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one uh so are you you know here's
our action we start we're an idol we
took a wrong action we took a correct
action and int
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and you and my membership is going to
come back to the random side of this and
there's a few different formulas they
use for the random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using do their standard one
because someone's usually gone in and
done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10
sitting as a reward is seven fetching
has a rewro or to five
just kind of without doing like a a
means to using the bell curve for the
means value and like i said there's some
math you can put in there to pick um so
that you're more like so that running
has even a higher chance
but even if you were just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together uh so you
get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do 0 to 22
or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
1 to 5 would be fetching
and so forth you know the last 10.
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
you see that
if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end if you're at the end of wherever
you're at sitting gets a reward of one
um where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward so that becomes very
very less likely to happen but it still
might happen it still might have a
percentage of coming up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo
and so here's my anaconda this one i'm
actually using a python36 environment
that i set up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new python 3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
um
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
and we'll we'll take a look at that as
we come into it so we go ahead and start
with our location to state uh so we have
l1 l2 these are our nine locations one
to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be 0 1 2 3 4. it's just a mapping of our
location to a integer on there and then
we have our actions our actions are
simply
moving from
one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location 0 and go to location 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8.
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
um a continually growing table because
you can actually create a dynamic queue
table where you continually add in new
values as they arise
because
um if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then your memory
and your computer is gone or you know
does it's not gonna work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
uh well i do
i've been doing some work in stock
um and one of the questions that comes
out is to buy or sell the stock
and the stake coming in
might be
you might take a concrete way called
buckets
where anything that you predict is going
to return more than a certain amount of
money
the error for that stock that you've had
in the past you put those in buckets and
suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets
you realize you do have a limited amount
of information coming in you no longer
have a float number you now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should i buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing long
term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the
current feed say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and the so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just create
it says if basically if you're
this should match our cue table because
it's going to be
you have your state and you have your
action across the top if you remember
from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
um and of course if you were actually
doing a um something more connected your
reward would be based on
um the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
uh so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards uh
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
set up for location state and location
to state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
you remember
we had our two different rates
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to 0.75 and the
alpha set to 0.9
and we'll see that when we do the
formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we
on go next two sections
um
since we're going to keep it
short and sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent
so our agent
is going to have our initialization
where we send it all the information uh
we'll define ourself gamma equals gamma
we could have just set the gamma rate
down here instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here
we have our choice of actions
um we're going to go ahead and just
embed the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
uh self-generated and then a self state
to location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero setup on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location
so this is whatever we end up at rewards
new equals ending state plus ending
state equals 999 just kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead let's do this
so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here
let me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward so we want to look at
the current the rewards uh the new
reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new
current state
plus j
j being what is the next state we want
to try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's just do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
selection you might do something where
uh whatever the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random choice
that's usually where you start play with
it
uh and then we have our
reward section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
uh so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future setup in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our cue table that's all this is
on this one
that's right here we have um
self cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path we're going to
go ahead and get the optimal route we
want to find the best route in here and
so we've created a definition for the
optimal route down here
scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
cue table self
start location in location next location
route q
and it says while next location is not
equal to in location so while we can
still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
the next state looks at the q table and
says hey what's the next one with the
best value and then the next location we
go ahead and pull that in and we just
append it that's what's going on down
here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our cue table our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our cue
agent load them up with their alpha
gamma that we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
our goal is to
plot a course between l9 and l1
and we're gonna go through a hundred a
thousand iterations on here
and so when i run that it runs pretty
quick
uh why is this so fast um if you've been
running neural networks and you've been
doing all these other models you sit
here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful
if you have a small amount of
information coming in you very quickly
get an answer off of this even though we
went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have l
nine eight five two and one and that's
based on our reward table we had set up
on there and this is the shortest path
going between these different uh setups
in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun
set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course into
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are and that
brings us to the end of this video on
machine learning algorithms i hope you
liked it
if you have any questions then please
put them in the comment section below
we'll be happy to answer them thank you
for watching and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you